[Music]
oprah posted an
image of george floyd this morning
including the words your life still
matters
kerry washington wrote stay in the fight
adding
happy one year awakening and here at the
intersection where floyd was murdered
a peaceful observance was planned but
watch what happens during the reporter's
live shot
this bill of comprehensive police reform
uh to be
uh just got to be careful here with some
gunshots
excuse us the journalist was okay
witnesses reported as many as 30
gunshots about a block east of the
intersection
one person was injured but things
quickly returned to normal
despite the panic and gunfire nothing of
course will overshadow the national
outcry for racial equality
that floyd's death inspired and
hollywood was at the forefront
we need justice for george floyd i feel
like i've done videos against police
brutality
i feel like this is like my seventh time
people are tired of that
i am a man who is frustrated i'm
disappointed
i'm angry black lives have always
mattered
e.t spoke to kevin hart at george
floyd's memorial last june
you know what man it's not it's not
about me i think it's more about just
standing with the family
you know in a moment like this just
literally letting them know that they're
not alone
you know for me it was a no-brainer just
to come be a part of a mission
that's for good
[Music]